وفي خطوه تقارب جديده يعزم كل من وزراء
خارجيه تركيه والنظام السوري وايضا روسيا
لاجتماع قريبا في موسكو طبعا هذه اللقاءات
الاخيره باتت تشغيل بال السوريين في شمال
البلاد اكثر من القصف والجوع والنزوح
وقساوه الشتاء عوده المناطق الى سيطره
النظام وفقا ما وعدت به انقره تشكل كابوسا
لسكان الشمال والمعارضين هناك لان ذلك
يعني تنازلات كبيره ستاتي على حسابهم
اللفت في الامر هو الثلاثه التي تنتجها
انقر في استداراتها السياسيه نحو النظام
الاسد دون ان يكون الارتباطاتها المتينه
مع المعارضه السوريه ايت موانع كما بدا
طبعا وهنا ياتي السؤال الذي يشغل بال
المعارضه السوريه حاليا وفقه وسائل
الاعلام محليه هو ماذا ستحصل تركيا مقابل
كل هذه التنازلات وما الذي يضمن لها تحقيق
مصالحها في سوريا اول ما تريده انقره هو
او ما هو واضح على الاقل يتجسد بضمانات
يقدمها نظام الاسد
عادل مقاتلين الاكراد عن حدودها ونصف اي
مشروع قومي كردي في الشمال السوري لكن
ماذا عن الوجود الامريكي في المنطقه خصوصا
وان واشنطن لم تبدي اي موافقه قويه حتى
الان من التقارب التركي مع الاسد سوى
تصريح ممدد بالرغم من ذلك الا ان مسؤولين
اكراد عسكريين وسياسيين ما زالوا واثقين
من ان امريكا لن تسمح باي اثر هذا التقارب
على الاداره الذاتيه الكرديه في المنطقه
وقوتها